I quit drinking back in October like
like forever I for 18 years uh-huh I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna stop drinking
while my small my sons living in my
house just because I don't totally love
the way I do it and he's getting to an
age where he really does need me all the
time in the morning well yeah yeah yeah
Anne Hathaway at making that surprise
confession on The Ellen DeGeneres Show I
did one school run one day where I
dropped him off at school I wasn't
driving but I was hungover and that was
enough for me I didn't love that yeah
the actress and her husband Adam Shulman
welcomed their son Jonathan back in 2016
and not long after and started
production on her new thriller serenity
get drunk she emits a bar crawl with
co-star Matthew McConaughey and his wife
before shooting on the tropical island
of Mauritius also inspired her to give
up alcohol after she wound up at a
production meeting pull over I was just
kind of like stumbling in one eye open
and says she looks to her co-star for
inspiration on how to do the whole
parenting thing he's living his life
he's found the balance that I am
striving for the pair got candid with et
earlier this month about the struggle to
balance it all she has a family of a
family we travel with our families now
it's a it's a constant work in progress
to keep those things balanced of you
know to have our families with us when
we go to work yeah it takes care so much
because we go to work we get consumed in
[ __ ] when you do that in the families
back home you come back home and you're
in that you're in then you're in the red
with the relationship with here with
your other half yeah you're in the red
with the relationship as a father or a
mother because kids weren't there you're
in the red with your friendships
yourself with Julia and you're coming
out you're wandering you've Mike whoever
what I do it it's nice to have it at the
end of the day when you come home from
work and you've been consumed and you
have your child ask you the silliest my
most brilliant question me go oh yeah
there we go this is I just popped out of
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]